[Musik]
sehr schnell wieder dahin
kommen
[Applaus]
wir sind das hey du bist das heim sag
mal ich bin das heim
das glück der welt es liegt in unserer
hand
da bot mit herz ist fast gut darf was
ich sage du wirst entweder gott
verdammen gott verfluchen oder du wirst
zu ihm stehen
unglaublich unglaublich
klüter bis machers event gehen dir das
herz und werden so missbraucht wer hier
dabei ist und hier verbindlichkeit
erklärt ist in die armee gottes
eingetreten wir stehen unter kriegs
gesetzen und das dem ersten zug sind nun
alle medien bevor die nicht gefallen
sind steht der goliath noch verstehst
das ist unsere aufgabe diesen goliath
alle medien zu feiern sagt man
die jacksons mittsiebziger ihren
soundcheck
bis zum tag seines nicht merkte sie
denkt mehr den opel da wird da wird
lüge und wahrheit vermischt und da wird
missbrauch betrieben
zum aber am gut
[Musik]
diese schädelform legt dem wagen sie
erstickt wurde laute sorgen
sieht ihn und
[Musik]
reicht ihr die haare
er ist einer dieser söhne aber einer der
ausgestiegen ist wir zeigen allen
menschen das geheimnis wie man mit einer
unbeschreiblichen fülle an herrlichkeit
und himmlische herrlichkeit mit fließen
kann eine funktionierende familie ist
daher nichts weges aus der himmel auf
erden
stimmt das
ist bestimmt nötig sind also meine hand
in hand wischt und
stetigkeit viel und
es ist nur so dass es
tatsächlich
spielt sich irgendwann
die chance hat erst vor ein paar monaten
die sekte seines vaters verlassen und
damit dessen konzept durcheinander
gebracht
[Musik]
ich habe elf kinder auf die welt
gestellt mit meiner frau alle zusammen
sind heute unsere hardliner unsere
besten mitarbeiter unter diesem himmel
allesklar.de war alles von meinen
kindern gestellt gelenkt geführt
[Applaus]
mit seiner familie gewinnt ivo sasek
publikum sie verkörpert die heile welt
auch auf der bühne
[Musik]
über 20 jahre lang hat das bestens
funktioniert
[Musik]
und hier sind meine kinder und auch eine
erste schwiegertochter manchmal winkel
das ist die erste schwiegertochter
die schwiegertochter und drei söhne sind
in der zwischenzeit ausgestiegen und
erzählen heute von der anderen seite der
familie sasek von gewalt und
teufelsaustreibungen
wie intensiv die körperliche züchtigung
eine mit 20 uhr läuft also dass sich an
intrigen
magazin wer sich geschehe unter sicher
das ist ein nur noch rang eigentlich ja
dann ist es ist extrem fahrer übergangen
und setzt sich auf relativ
günstig und
oft begleitet von regierungs und
panischen
ganze familie nur noch
als sehr sehr dramatisieren
erlangen ist ja und wo halt wirklich
dann am schluss horizontalen pullis und
deiner free steckt und ich weiß nicht
hat dann mein kopf auf der steig oder
druckt vista ist und wenn ich bin ich
froh dass das leben des lag das ist die
aktiven vom
bodensee das ist dann
eine badstuber dann ist
das ist der schlag nach roja und dann
hat es zum glück
sich in dieser welt zurechtfinden die
ihm noch fremd ist
joshua der 28 jahre lang nur die sekte
seines vaters gekannt hat er lebt heute
allein in einer zwei zimmer wohnung
hier oben hat er bis vor kurzem gelebt
in walzenhausen im hauptsitz der otg der
organischen christus generation
das zimmer hat er mit dem bruder geteilt
und ausschließlich für die sekte des
vaters gearbeitet
schlimm stellte sie das ich mir nie
tankstelle mitarbeiter und und die
teaminterne ich mich gut verstanden
haben wir jetzt
alles verlore
relation oder
der sturm überstanden hätte
wir fragen bei ivo sasek mehrmals nach
für ein interview er lehnt ab
einige fragen wird er schriftlich
beantworten doch keine antwort gibt er
auf die frage warum haben sie ihren sohn
geschlagen
in walzenhausen nahm damals alles seinen
anfang
[Musik]
der ehemalige automechaniker ivo sasek
beginnt mit einer kleinen gemeinschaft
heute füllt er seele wir rühmen sich als
der herr über jedem atom und jede
molekül das leben hier unten ist nicht
einfach um es schön zu haben das leben
hier und ist eine leidenschaft von line
ist er präsent und erreicht so
mittlerweile ein millionenpublikum
[Applaus]
wir stehen miteinander echt an einer
gewaltigen schwelle ja ich sage wir
stehen mitten im endkampf
[Applaus]
ich will dass du mir sagst du bist wie
ich lebe
[Musik]
ivo sasek ist multimedial präsent
ich mache regelmäßig große spielfilme
ich bin gleichzeitig vorstehe von tvs
und
ghz gab willkommen in der neuen welt
willkommen in der neuen welt
also jeder ist jeder hat am morgen das
inhalieren was wie ein vater prediger
und
ohne dass verliert man gebote und da
kommt das alles
verstehen
dass das schöne
gedanklich mal in frage stellen sich die
größte schritt für mich
[Musik]
simon der bruder von joshua er war der
erste der die radikale gemeinschaft des
vaters verlassen hat
die medaillen sind mittlerweile
36 gestiegen sind am 8
ja also ich bin halt schon ganz große
brocken im reinheft dass die
einheitliche schöne familie wo alle und
licher strand sind kaputt gegangen ist
und dass jetzt ausgestiegen sind
simon und seine frau mia waren beide
fest verankert in der oecd vor sechs
jahren sind sie nach einer dramatischen
flucht ausgestiegen er der als
nachfolger galt hat sich mit seiner
familie von seinem vater abgewendet für
ivo sasek ist er seither ein aussätziger
und einer der von dämonen besessen ist
er hat mir vor der ersten stunde des
akteurs zeit will ich weg dieser
therapien vor der kriegsfront
angeblich und zum finden über gewechselt
haben aber ich habe vom rechtsstaat
gewechselt und waren oder salz gesiedet
seht dann ist gab es probleme habe es
innere sie diese tür verschließen in der
regel ist österreich und das hat er mir
gesagt dass akteure werden zuschüsse und
hat auch bibelzitat dann braucht aber
wieder hinterher info fluss dass
vertreter mit steiniger werden und mit
und braucht wäre
wir fahren nach igls unweit von chur in
der schweiz und in deutschland
verbreiten sechs anhänger dessen
botschaften übers internet
zb aus diesem wohnhaus
hier wird die wohnstube zum
nachrichtenstudio für sechs
internetsender klar tv
wir möchten uns das genauer anschauen
doch wir werden gleich weg gewiesen
klar tv wird produziert von seiner
anhängerschaft alle arbeiten
ehrenamtlich
vielen dank an meine kollegin in st
gallen so geht der zuschauer ins lido
zuschauer ich darf sie heute zu einer
nicht ganz leichten kost begrüßen sussex
sender klar tv verbreitet primär
verschwörungstheorien
5g ist gefahr für leib und leben
dringender weckruf
tausende sterben nach corona impfung wir
ziehen deshalb in dieser sendung bilanz
über drei monate kroner impfpraxis über
drei millionen klicks generiert allein
dieser film eine beachtliche reichweite
tragen sie dazu bei dass dieser
dringende weckruf jeden menschen
erreicht da ist ja aus erklärte ziel zum
die art wie die vergrößerung und das
steht über dem ziel wahrheit verbreiten
oder
kombiniert irgend fake news gebe sogar
über die flache erde verbreitet werden
so langsam reicht wie die bedient und
deshalb dienst 10 jährig als als
alternative medium wo das über allem
steht und uns erklärte ziel ich zum
größten media für europa werben klatt ev
versteht sich auch als historisches
archiv der gegenstimmen als pflicht
zeugen des zeitgeschehens die geschichte
der flachen erde nach dem klar tv
kürzlich die flache erde theorie als
gegenstimme zum heliozentrischen bild
präsentiert hat erlauben wir uns heute
sie auf eine weitere gegenstimme
aufmerksam zu machen sämtliche von der
nasa veröffentlichten erdkugel aufnahmen
wurden laut nasa mitarbeiter robert
simmen mit photoshop erstellt sie schaut
die ultimative verunsicherung weil man
mit dem konfrontiert wird und da sind
die tatsache dass er geschrieben dann
verunsichert das wie sieht wohl
keine kräftigen sind bildet sind wie
auch immer fehlt ein paar cloud werden
minimiert der glashütter dass der däne
schieben ist ja tatsächlich
und er glaube
es hat der pause glaube und vielleicht
sogar überhaupt hat und dann irgendwann
hat es glaubt dann schwankt das einfach
als partner als opportunist das ganze
kino hat zum die mit klicks generieren
und die sitte gibt es über leitern wie
im halbfinale so lerne relativ
schmerzvoll wie ich immer druck lobte
dass er überzeugt ist von dem was er rät
deutschland im krieg gegen russland
von ivo sasek bitte macht auf ihr
deutschen wacht auf ihr europäer alle im
namen deutschlands beliefert hier ein
tollkühner schutzes klein gerade ein
land mit waffen das sich im krieg mit
russland befinden dieser clan gehört
darum rechtzeitig vor einer von
nürnberger kriegs tribunal der dritte
weltkrieg ist dann eine realität und
zwar genau so wie er in den satanischen
schriften vorgezeichnet ist ich sage
alle schulz ins gehirn überdies
rechtzeitig frühzeitig vor ein
kriegsgericht und kriegs tribune navi
nürnberger werk sieht sich als führer
von gottes gnaden als
herrscher aber auch als prophet also
keine trennung kirche und staat sondern
religion und politik ist ein und
dasselbe muss sich demokratie das ist
dass man dafür kommt und diese praxis
ist das also in der oecd zeit etwa gott
herrscht aber in der praxis ist er der
dax macht das erste direkte macht kommt
und sagt wie es läuft
in der churer stadthalle treffen wir uns
hier drinnen finden die veranstaltungen
von ivo sasek statt und hier drinnen
habe er gesehen wie menschen seelisch
geistig missbraucht wurden
wieviel sehr beliebt
[Musik]
so bleibt man schlafen rammelvoll isches
doxil rahmen des emmy braucht alles
mitbrachte stuhl mit brachte schmid
brocken hat alles mit braucht er will
dass ich das mit mir eigentlich im herz
weh tut oder wird lüth
freigebig sinti viethen geändert bis
machen sie wenn teil von der familie sie
merken nicht wie sie missbraucht werden
70 jacksons mit ihren soundcheck ich
gebe es zu ich wasche ihnen die hirne
sowie euch heute um zu zeigen was
wahrheit und was lüge ist aber auch so
zeigen wie man menschen dient er macht
macht er möchte einfach macht hat das
sich einfach so da setzt
alles in bewegung damit die macht über
grund und dani clos über kunden in
verschiedenen szenen alle werden von
denselben 16 jährigen mit denselben
beschuldigungen denselben fiesen
methoden hinters licht geführt also ich
habe mich aufgemacht ich habe gesagt
jungs steht ließ com kommen sie sind per
sie bitte sie auf die bühne das ist es
einer der köpfe so wie ich im kopf bin
von acg ist einen kopf und scientology
psychologen hallo heißt du gekommen alle
herzlich willkommen
ich werde am meisten angegriffen weil
ich mit den scientologen
im bund steht
ivo sasek bittet umstrittene
organisationen und personen auf seine
bühne so hat er seine anhängerschaft die
möglichkeit sich umfassend zu
informieren
er kennt die schlagzeilen über den iran
sie können schlecht nicht sein dass
braucht eine gegenstimme
zu einem zeitpunkt als wegen dem
atomprogramm sanktionen gegen den iran
verhängt werden bittet er den iranischen
botschafter auf seine
[Musik]
hand aus familie im iranischen
botschafter für die schweiz haben jetzt
meter gasse und und super super zieht
sie sind ganz italien salami und seine
familie entwickelt iran eine atombombe
jahren ein was sagen sie dazu dass
müssen sie uns schon noch können die
unbekannt wie in der wo in die region
das einzige land dort in dieser region
ruhig heißt nuclear bombs das überhaupt
atomare bewaffnung hat
und das ist nicht die islamische
republik vom iran
sondern es ist das gebilde das sich
israel nennt warum der botschafter hier
aufgetreten sei fragen wir beim
iranischen konsulat nach auf unsere
anfrage bekommen wir keine antwort
auch eine mehrfach verurteilte
holocaust-leugner in dafür
uneingeschränkt regen
[Musik]
hat den mut eines löwen möchte ich
einmal sagen sie ist stärker aus einem
mann ich habe nie eine frau
kennengelernt mit mehr profil
für das was sie hier in chur sagen wird
wird sie danach in deutschland zu 18
monaten gefängnis verurteilt
pixie
lott
das herz der internist vielen
feststellungen über eine unter der
herrschaft des nationalsozialismus vor
gelegene absicht die judenheit ganz oder
teilweise zu zerstören es fehlen die
feststellung über tatorte
tötungsmethoden anzahl der toten tat
zeiträume
täter
leichen oder spuren eines mordes
stolz schließt ihr referat mit dem
appell es kindern gleich zu tun und war
zu sein mit diesen eigenschaften
schaffen wir es vielleicht eine welt zu
schaffen in der man die wahrheit sagen
darf ohne bestraft zu werden
wenn bereits davor stellte sie 2000
liegt und mehrmals gestanden dass
er
traut sich an industrie
wo seit irgendwie und kommentator und
den klatschen alle
aufgestanden hat das stimmt nicht
buseck wird für den auftritt von sylvia
stolz auch in der schweiz angezeigt und
freigesprochen die frau saß und adolf
hitler seinen kindern empfiehlt er schon
früh mein kampf von adolf hitler zu
lesen
und will er aber davon überzeugt dass
kampf gott direkt nach der biblischen
es hat der pause
gab 2009 wurden verträge über zeigt sich
dass adolf hitler im rang von apostel
ich es kommen reihenweise neue bücher
von hochgradigen historischen auf den
markt die ein komplett anderes bild zb
von adolf hitler zeichnen versteht ihr
dass du sagst du hast da darf man nicht
mal denken das ist ein teufel und jetzt
wenn das eine war der bereich nachher
ist es christus kommt was machst du dann
mit dass einer ist bei von rang ist
eines apostels jetzt ernste mich an
verboten so was zu sagen
hast das geprüfte hat geprüft schon mal
als ich kam er an seht ihr
fazit der undifferenzierte
texas
und von dem
iveco
aber
erfolgt immer noch antisemitische dank
muster und antisemitische
[Musik]
stereotype
buseck bestreitet judenfeindlich zu sein
und schreibt uns ich liebe alle menschen
gleich auch alle juden wir sind seit je
absolut gegen jede gewalt gegen jede
form des rassismus und diskriminierung
von minderheiten
[Musik]
2009 kommt austausch zusammen mit seiner
frau in die oecd er steigt nach sieben
jahren aus sie ist geblieben
als faschist christ
er steckte damals in einer persönlichen
krise
und suchte hilfe und erlöse
um ihn dort zu geben ja hat er sich ja
witzig wenige sagt
ich bin vom herzen an gerechtigkeit
mensch und den hermine kinderring sagt
einer der dort zur frage stellte gemacht
und wie man den link schick vor dem und
den hatte der linke block content denke
mir wahrheit aber rückgrat wenn der
schutz auch in den haller da dort die
finanzen und damals als möglicher was
also halt
und bei dem ein könner andere auto wort
co das hat mir gefallen dass andere auf
der mall nicht dem mainstream ist
deshalb blockiert aber da hatte den
surfer zu wort kommt das hat mich
fasziniert andere litz gehören
17 jahre kölner blieben ziehen
weg der in folge vor der otg eines
verloren er alles also ivo sasek dort
das öffentlich sage das motto nimm also
zugangscodes eg das sind
die akteure ja das tut man kriegt
verschlüsseln oder das sind diese töne
und sie sind deshalb mit leberkranken
aussätzige und was macht man mit uns
sechziger da kommt man in riesa bogen
drum mit zusätzlicher tgv
gefahren und so eine frau verloren offen
schlag die dem moment ohne galopp intakt
und fertig geschrieben und das dort
natürlich weh oder
[Musik]
osv hat damals viel investiert in das
werk von ivo sasek arbeit und geld
bringt es voll in die ganze sache und
den wald das praktisch als erschlug und
dabei sich sowieso gratis gemacht mit
der intensiv gehe ich auch viel zu viel
wie viel 500 franken monat über jahre
über jahre ja und frauenfeld man sich
einverstanden erklären dass man sich
einig börse ag dass das nicht an it
messe ag aber nicht mehr kritisch weil
die patienten immer wieder gott das werk
unterstützt und genau das droht eine
balance muss er nutzt das aus dass man
das erweist lügt wenn bis kurz vor jeder
macht gerne bis kurz vor und genau das
muss darüber muss also maßlos das
prinzip von ivo sasek gemeinschaft
niemand muss doch alle helfen seine
schätzungsweise 2500 anhängerinnen und
anhänger machen alles
[Musik]
und alles gratis
er liegt jetzt aufgekommen weil der
technische zins wird gefilmt dass es
lauft es dass das fasziniert oder
aber dass ich aber der körper das ist
genau die eltern weil es immer
interessant ist auch vermieter tötet sie
während der zeit ich damals setzt oder
als onkel hans peter schäfer von der
spalten und so
interessant deshalb bislang
viel
trägt gleich null ich habe 30 jahre lang
gratis gearbeitet
jede lohn den ich je hatte habe ich
immer verschenken ich habe nie einen
müden heller für irgendetwas verlangt
ich habe nie seit 30 jahren einen
einzigen
spendenaufruf gemacht nie von einem
dienst etwas verlangt und da kommt der
hugo stamm daher versteht hier ein
16-jähriger da konnte er von von tages
anzeiger
wo bist du was seid ihr die lüge was
liegt jetzt zusammen und der zeit den
leuten in zeitungen dass ich ihm geld
mensch bin woher nehmen sie das ich
beschwöre euch hier lügen woher nehmt
ihr das warum sagt ihr einem ivo sasek
dann nimmt das volk nimmt ihnen das geld
aus der tasche und nehmt ihr das
haye
ja
halleluja
wenn sie 500 gehend im monat das hätten
mitglieder
man schätzt sie den wir für die stadt
seine hormone ja aber carlos rechner zum
internet 70 mitglieder
taxi-unternehmer redsnow show einfach
wahrnehmen des gt300 franka monats pro
person manche gehen erhöht manche sehr
viel aber wenn er einfach nur mal ganz
banaler betrag alle immer mit hundert
frau kadenz im alltagsbetrieb million
oder nicht
eine weitere wichtige einnahmequelle im
hauptsitz in walzenhausen arbeiten für
ivo sasek schätzungsweise 14 menschen
ohne lohn mangels einkommen bekommen sie
krankenkassen verbilligung jährlich sind
das zehntausende franken damit
unterstützt der staat indirekt die oecd
wie rechtfertigen sie das wollen wir von
ivo sasek wyss die frage beantwortet er
nicht
ivo sasek gehören allein in walzenhausen
drei liegenschaften laut grundbuch ist
er alleineigentümer
auch dieses haus gehört ihm genauso die
fahrzeuge die seine familie und sein
team nutzen dürfen er gewährt ihnen
zudem kost und logis und hin und wieder
eine ferienreise
auch das panorama zentrum in st
margrethen wo seine filme produziert
werden gehört ausschließlich ihn
mit nichts hat er die sekte des vaters
verlassen für die er ohne lohn
gearbeitet hat joshua sec hat kein
erspartes keine pensionskasse und kaum
gelder in der ahv
aber ich glaube also ich sag
mal
bist du habe ich mir jetzt viel
zu großzügig
haben sie in jahr regelmäßig meine
brockhaus gesenkt werden
regelmäßig geben und war verdient
trinkgeld aber sie in die 1
ja es ist so dass der tag der arbeit
dann direkt
in den stehenden flossen ist ja gut alle
imame alles über den alles was ich
geschafft habe ich
natürlich gerne auf sein konto gelandet
und er hat dann können damit bis hafen
[Musik]
seine kinder würden aus freien stücken
für ihn arbeiten und auf lohn verzichten
sagt ivo sasek
joshua hat eine ausbildung zum
konstrukteur gemacht und arbeitet heute
als technischer projektleiter er kommt
langsam an in diesem neuen oft noch
unbekannten leben
[Musik]
es
sind so zocker worte des staates ohne
geld ist und dass
das ist für alle danone galt ist
das hat man nicht
gesehen also kann er steckte schluss
sony unia will er stieg an ihre
versierte haben kurzerhand als richtig
realisieren könnte alles sein vater man
meint man sich äußerst positiv
aber die momente wo man danach liegt
viel kritisiert realisiert man dass
damit eine salbe gehört
selbstständig und frei im geist sei er
heute
und am verarbeiten was gewesen sei und
nie mehr sein wird
ich mache gern das ist so aber
stand's schon
sehr viel schaden
angerichtet weiß nicht wer das sagen
hat eine schwere partie
ivo sasek soll einmal gesagt haben wenn
eines seiner kinder sein werk verlassen
höre er auf drei söhne sind ausgestiegen
doch er macht weiter wie bisher
jetzt braucht es euch es braucht euch
alle und darum sage ich folgt jetzt
diesem aufruf bildet eure fachgruppen
tut den mund auf stellt euch hin für
eine welt die sonst verloren ist ich bin
über sah sich der 43 jahre verkürzt wird
auch er hofft aber nicht auf ivo sasek
auf seine frau die er verloren hat
das ist meine frau friedrich georg
reiter
und die absender und eines tages glaube
nach wie vor dass sie dass sie
wiederkommt dass sie der
dass sie die
sicht über kunst dass es ganz bestimmt
vor gott die sicht über kommt dass sie
weniger auf
die lüge und wahrheit können
unterscheiden aber jetzt
ist ja voll setzt sich die natürliche
holding aber das kann man nicht
erzwingen
das muss das foto einer plötzlich gesagt
man das
[Musik]